Sam Jackson with two eyeballs yeah don't
eat you don't even need de-aging
tickling he's a wig for him
feels like Sam Jackson like the same
forever I know I could see some of the
de-aging here oh yeah great I'm sure
they did it it looks really really good
though I mean that looks like a heat a
natural young photo still of Sam Jackson
20 years ago so that does look great
he's got an injury they're getting into
a heap of trouble see doing paperwork
it's shield yeah says here's a desk
jockey who hasn't yet met any
superheroes
he wants to real bad though he's trying
to find this that's why he's gonna crash
this train by the end of the movie it's
gonna be great hey boss how you doing
Nick here I brought that coffee for you
I don't want the confident in control I
want the guy who's like delivering mail
around the office achieve we're gonna
see that the new origin of how he loves
his eyen truthfully it's just going to
somebody threw hot coffee
this is Mordor yeah your fury what's
happening to reject nation greg alba
donald we are the woman who are leading
this female empowerment movement in
superheroes cinema today II W has
released their exclusive first look at
Captain Marvel excuse me if I'm a little
low on energy
I a little bit under the weather but
with that in mind I wanted to give a
patron today shoutout to a man named
David Gallacher it's ch he are weird
but he's a good-looking guy this
gentleman he's a fairly new patron he is
from Scotland school I'm studying to be
a pharmacist he said his passion to help
out people give them some drugs I wish I
lived in Scotland because I could buy so
many prescriptions from you yeah I would
focus all the doctors know all the
adderall
then the vicodin go to sleep at night
extra Agra's I'm telling you buddy if
you can just move your profession to the
states
you get yourself a number one customer
right now I would say don't pledge to
patreon anymore if anything just give us
a bunch of meds just give us a bunch of
medication some we can turn over for a
profit you know
sand because we believe in wholesale
Daniel I'm glad you're here buddy rarely
meet someone all the way from Scotland
so it's nice to know you exist I hope
you're excited for Captain Marvel
because you seem like one happy male
woman so let's move on to these photos
shall we people have been asking all
right I'm gonna make a disclaimer we
don't really know too much about Captain
Marvel did a bunch of research yesterday
because I heard this was coming out I
was Captain Marvel for Halloween and
fourth grade has a terrible costume so I
just want to say that you know if
there's something we don't know feel
free to educate us in the comment boxes
and I know this is YouTube so you guys
will do it with the utmost respect
because we're asking sincerely and
kindly to just let us know some more
information so we can be educated I know
in no way will there be any hate coming
our way
for not knowing a piece of information
that you would like us to have already
known prior to do in this video thanks
for waiting until this portion before
commenting I've just loaded the site
I've seen one image already prior to
doing this video and it's this one right
here which goes along the lines of every
Captain Marvel photo I've seen of her
this same blank she's super cute and the
stairs you still got the same blank
stare and the suit right here it's a
cool picture it's the suit I'm used to
seeing soon I expected to see so like
cool that it still exists I guess and
isn't green because I know that made
some people ask Eevee some people were
pretty upset by that or maybe that's
just an old suit when she's a part of
the Kree or something when she's in the
Star Force group Star Fox the S stands
from okay yeah okay as we go to the next
photo there's that green suit right
there yeah this is my comment boxes
exist so you guys can help educate us is
that it looks like homeboy from
guardians of the galaxy that is
definitely a Ronan the accuser and
Digimon hunt see whatever that carrot
core app there's something like that
yeah but I read last night was that she
was she's part of the Kree Star Force
this is before guardians of the galaxy
obviously so this is kind of fascinating
to me she's a good person in this movie
so I'm wondering is this gonna
transition into when Ronan
comes a bad guy where the kree bad I
don't know any of that back store like
an uneasy like are they walk it yeah I
like I don't want to be working with you
because I know that you're shady but you
know yeah it's not been revealed yet
yeah exactly like is it gonna lead into
what we see them in the introduction of
in guardians of the galaxy and that's
something that I've being very curious
about this entire time ku and then right
here we got the commander of Star Force
Jude Law here sexy and ageless as ever
who I hear is you know Carol's mentor
yeah which is exactly what we need if
we're gonna transition women to the
cinema I'm gonna have a man train that
need a man to show them the way and for
all the women and men who don't pick up
on sarcasm this is not sorry yeah that's
it we're not that dark if you want to
get mad at me for making that comment
totally cool jazz I want a hundred
percent mean it totally justified
there's quotes here already the quotes
that we got here on the side let's go
back a photo the film sidesteps a
traditional orange and story template
and when it begins carol has already has
her powers Oh kind of like spider-man
homecoming yeah a little bit you know
except in homecoming we already got two
origins of spider-man so we didn't need
another origin no origin of Carroll but
screw it let's just hop right into who
she is already we've got time works for
DC she's left her earthly life behind to
join the elite military team star force
in the Kree planet of hollow man if I
had just read this and wouldn't have had
to try to go off the memory I know they
said she was an ex-pilot and then some
accident occurs that causes her to get
powers they combine her DNA with like
Kree DNA so that's how she has some like
alien like super abilities it seems like
this star force thing especially off
this imagery like she's the leader of it
x-force that's cool of her that's really
cool of her that she comes from a
different planet and then she goes to
this planet and now she's the leader of
it look at that we already get to see
what she'd be like leading a team hmmm
interests never know when that could
come in handy in the future in the
future say when Captain America leaves
director Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck
described Star Force is the SEAL Team
six of space that's it's even more
impressive because space is a lot bigger
than Earth to establish a space force
well I have a feeling that other than
Korath these other seal team members are
gonna die yeah man I'm getting except
for maybe Jemma Chan cuz they named her
here maybe crazy rich Asians blowing up
maybe they went back shot some extra for
like we gotta get you in this movie all
right let's go back to the jewel a photo
mysterious it says right there
mysterious man sir man I mean you do any
research Entertainment Weekly has laid
this the groundwork for me Jude Law
plays the commander Star Force these
extraordinary powers she has he sees him
as something of a blessing and something
that she has to learn how to control
that's the motif throughout the pace the
element of learning to control one's
emotions and to use your powers wisely
conceal don't feel you know for a movie
that's saying you're not gonna you know
really dive into the origin of her
powers and stuff this quote right here
seems a lot like you're going to it
maybe it's the emotional journey of the
powers versus how did she get them
physically okay yeah there might be that
that's a good point that's a good point
you think Jude Law might have bulked up
a little bit more but he does look a
little bit more buff than the usual
skinniness that he possesses he'll dive
our way through he's not getting buff
for thank God men and green these must
be the scrolls let's confirm that yes it
is the scroll is the nastiest and most
notorious I hear they have like
shape-shifting abilities oh boy I like
this image of them washed up here on the
Santa Monica beach I don't know that's
ben mendelsohn in the lead right there
who's leading the pack but but damn does
he look dry yeah came out of the water
looking dry it's like back to the future
you know yeah it's the night all right
double duty as any Marvel comic fans
knows the scrolls are especially
dangerous because the unparalleled
ability to shape-shift yay I got a fact
right before it ready on earth
mendelssohn's Talos goes oh that is ben
mendelsohn right here working for the
IOI goes undercover as a human were
Kien within shield not easy being green
Kermit I thought he was that like NBC
News reporter recognize ben mendelsohn
at all here I like their credibility for
those cutaways to the news yeah this
movie's being directed by two people
actually I didn't know that so yesterday
which seems like it's lately been
happening a little more and I'm always
curious as to how cuz the DGA is pretty
Stern about those things yes and they
usually have to have like some great
reason to budge or whatever yes directed
by Anna Bowden and Ryan Fleck you know
you gotta have at least one of them be a
woman it would ya be a good but you
can't go full woman no like I said no
sarcasm ever we've never used it we
don't do satire we don't do that and
when it fits off my girlfriend will oh
that's familiar out here is a better
look at Ronan an outcast with extremist
views but here he's still a high-ranking
member of the Kree society yeah you know
I I feel like he can get his due with
something along the lines of what
happened with Loki in a way I mean you
didn't go back and see Loki's whole
origin or whatever and another movie but
a lot of people really liked him in the
first Thor
I personally was kind of whatever about
Loki honestly it wasn't until his second
film adventures when I'm like Loki's
awesome you know even with guardians of
the galaxy Ronan was it was a villain
that was set up to be a very memorable
and impactful villain but ultimately in
the end he wasn't bring it down hard
one of the more alright ones like Lee
pace I thought brought something to that
character but the character could have
used more yeah I'm hoping that more than
just hey cool this guy from guardians is
back in here that we really get a chance
to explore Ronan a little bit more that
way we can have more of a stronger
memory of who the guy is a better
understanding and I would like it to
have that effect where when you go back
and watch guardians it's even more
impactful because you've seen Captain
Marvel yeah I mean everybody harps on
Marvel's quote villain problem and I
think this is a cool opportunity
especially with them
running out jumping around in time you
know seeing another character who we've
already been acquainted with get maybe
recontextualized could be yeah a cool
thing for them over on maybe that'll
open the door for other characters to
come back and get more flesh over time
you know flesh like a woman like oh look
we got this new image of Captain Marvel
she loves Nine Inch Nails wearing it
because it's the 90s
yeah pretty hate machine he's dressed
like a 90s girl and she still has the
same stare she's had since that feeling
had artists our force and being Captain
Marvel she has the exact same changer
hey hey hey she have facial expressions
in this movie know they're gonna use
that d aging tech to move their face all
around for her got it okay that well
this looks awesome
yeah I was reading stuff from quotes
about her saying how she Captain Marvel
is a character like a temper and being
aggressive and she even talked about her
sense of humor I wanted like one of the
directors was was saying how she has a
sense of humor even though she like
makes jokes that a lot of people don't
find funny there's these qualities about
her that make her feel very human that
everyone keeps talking about
Doreen Larsen and the directors and yet
every time I see a photo of her it's the
same blank stare that's the one thing
these photos haven't given me is
personality yeah I always feel like the
scenes about to start in every one of
these pictures Hey
she's almost making a face yeah before
she became Captain Marvel Carroll was an
accomplished Air Force pilot and Larson
spent time with actual pilots for
research an hour one hour on a Skype
call with the pilot while she was on a
road trip one sec I gotta check the
speed that's cool so altitude change and
breathing in the air go up and forward I
get it oh hi oh that's cool you can't
reverse a beard hey she's coming out of
the plane yeah she just came flying and
she has the same stare she's got that
you got the flying high right there
that's how cool she is nothing fazes
nothing fazes her damn even this photo
of lashana Lynch has more emotion than
any other photos looks like she's Lee's
happy to be in that plane oh time by the
way I want everyone to read into our
comments so heavily about Captain Marvel
and not having facial expressions we're
serious we're serious we know this these
photos are the best reflection of what
the movie is gonna be like no I don't
need to wait for a trailer I don't even
you see the actual movie I have
concluded that she is gonna be
completely emotionless the entire time
like I said no sarcasm so she's playing
Maria Rambo John Rambo's
great-great-granddaughter yeah it's one
of those confusing things like when Jeff
Goldblum had a black daughter and you're
not gonna even bring it up drama she's
black just does it tell me a little bit
he's clearly ohdo white guy yes take a
situation I would like to know more
about his family she's top notch Air
Force plywood the callsign Photon and
she's also a single mother to a young
daughter all right look I start
rewriting your film I want this movie
photon my captain photon captain no just
them just Maria Scott Maria and it's
about her being a single mother being a
pilot having to deal with her her baby
daddy oh yeah
Marvel you know the bumper comes up the
ve elbow
fadeaway replaced by an ia and here it
is the Entertainment Weekly photo cover
here I always feel strangely when they
do covers like this where it's like a
totally action II pose but again that
same kind of blank expression she's got
an eyebrow cocked she's got a little bit
of the Dwayne Johnson going on there wow
wow that is a shiny CW looking out
yeah Marvel's bright this looks great
and it looks from the comic images I've
seen you know not from an actual comic
Google images from stand-ups who have
told me about the Cummings from J
Washington this looks accurate
it looks like brie Larson and a
supersuit
it looks like the super suit she's
supposed to be wearing yeah this costume
looks great I don't know why her face is
just like literally guys she's they must
have just superimposed her face same
face and every single photo not me
because many expressions she just been
directed in these moments and she's just
listening like what's going on here or
is it one of those Ryan Gosling roles
like that's how a lot of photos can be
but it is really weird to see a bunch of
them together we're like they're all not
even one like give me one leg I just to
just to show that hothead yeah where's
the person now I know I've seen some
like you know behind-the-scenes photos
where she's like this is some good
teases I think this I mean I'm my
expectation as an edge trailers probably
right around the corner at this moment
yeah I feel like what weirdly has got a
meme posting like as much as I've been
excited for Captain Marvel because I I
genuinely am really looking forward to
this movie despite all the sarcastic
comments I really am looking forward to
this movie I think there's plenty in
here to look for to this thing that I
haven't thought at all about until these
photos is Ronin and Korath being in this
movie and strangely enough that's gotta
mean like the most intrigued from these
photos everything else is what I have
expected yeah that was like oh yeah
they're in this I forgot about that yeah
I think kind of it's almost more fun to
see what happens when side characters
and and you know fringy or elements
crossover there's like oh it's Iron
Man's back you know things like that
alright guys well these photos do
something for you did they not it's
Captain Marvel your new favorite
superhero put it in the comments below
guys you can subscribe to the reject
nation and click that notification bow
check us out on patreon where we got
full-length TV show reactions and weekly
Q&A s don't you love when people do
videos about photos it's always worth
it makes sense